Speaker 1: Let's talk next about an op ed
in The Washington Post by Max Boot. Now,
I want to give a disclaimer, Max Boot. Max Boot
is being seen as just a horrible, neoliberal,
terrible person by many people, other people
like Max Boot. I don't really care what you
think about Max Boot. Max Boot has written a very
interesting piece. The Washington Post called
the Republican plot to steal the 2004 election,
and he outlines many of the ways that the 2004
election could go, saying Republicans have spent
nearly seven months making bogus charges of fraud
in the 2012 election under the banner of Stop
the Steal. Now they've segued into a start the
Steele offensive to ensure that they will win the
2022 and 2024 elections. Even if most voters once
again support the Democratic Party. This is
important. They're still talking about 20 20,
but they're actually planning for twenty, twenty
two and twenty twenty for the Brennan Center for
Justice reports that between January one and
May 14, at least 14 states enacted 22 new laws.
That's not even what's proposed, right?
Look, proposals are in the hundreds
that restrict access to the vote. And at least
61 bills with restrictive provisions are moving
through 18 state legislatures. These bills are
designed not to avert nonexistent voter fraud,
but to avert another election defeat for
Republicans. And they are drawing perilously
close to that goal. Max points out some of the
specific cases in Georgia, which we've discussed
in Texas and in other places. But what I think is
most important here is the big picture analysis
where Max Boot writes, While Republican efforts
are ultimately aimed at the 2024 election,
they will first make their impact felt in twenty.
Twenty two off year elections are always tough for
the party in power. This one will be tougher still
because of Republican driven voter suppression,
reapportionment and gerrymandering. Dave
Wasserman of the Cook Political Report writes that
Republicans will have full authority to redraw one
hundred and eighty seven congressional districts
while Democrats will control just 75.
The gerrymandering will get worse.
He estimates that redistricting in just four
states Texas, Florida, Georgia and North Carolina
could be enough to deliver the House to Republican
control. This brings us to a nightmare scenario.
A Republican controlled Congress overturning
the twenty twenty four presidential election
results to install Trump or a Trump
M.E. in the White House in January.
One hundred and thirty nine House Republicans
and eight Senate Republicans voted not to certify
the Electoral College results in at least one
state. Since then, the most prominent Republican
opponent of the Big Lie, Congresswoman Liz
Cheney, has been purged from the House leadership.
Willingness to lie about election fraud
has become a litmus test for Republicans,
with the implicit threat of mob violence if they
don't go along. Republicans are so scared of Trump
and his fanatical followers that most of them
just voted against the bipartisan investigation
of the January 6th attack on the Capitol. If you
think that they aren't going to try even harder
in twenty, twenty two and twenty twenty four, just
you wait. They have given up policy. The Republic.
What policy is the Republican Party for right now?
They've abandoned policy, it's obstruct Democrats
and try to win by legislating who can vote and how
easy it is for certain people to vote, they are
going to do what they did in twenty, twenty times.
Ten in twenty, twenty two end times. Twenty in
twenty, twenty four. Max Boot goes on to say many
congressional Republicans will refuse to certify
a twenty 24 Democratic win in swing states. If
Republicans control Congress, they could deny
the Democrats an Electoral College majority and
throw the election to the House, where each state
delegation, regardless of population, would cast
one ballot. Given that Republicans already control
a majority of state delegations, they could
override the election outcome. If that happens,
it would spell the end of American democracy.
Now, if you don't think Republicans would do this.
Come on, guys, they January 6th, look at January
6th, look at even now, later in the show,
Donald Trump is now saying he thinks
he might be reinstated in August.
Multiple Republicans and right wing media
figures Michael Flynn, Tucker Carlson,
Matt Gates are talking about let's use guns to get
what we need. Let's do a real insurrection. Let's
do a coup like Coolac in Myanmar or M.R.,
as Michael Flynn's audience member said,
if you don't think they're willing to do
this, what will stop them from doing this
is if they're unable to, but they are going
to try and, you know, the the specifics of
can they really do it this way? Can they really
do it that way? Could the house alone pull this
off? Don't they need the Senate as well? Yeah,
we're going to look at all of those scenarios,
but they have too many options as the
problem. If they could look at putting in
Trump's there's trumpeter's, whatever you call
them, as secretaries of states in the Midwest,
still not easy in twenty twenty two, but maybe
for twenty, twenty four. And so this is something
they are going to do. 2016 was a warm up to
what they tried in twenty twenty. Fortunately
in twenty twenty Joe Biden just had
enough turnout that he ended up winning.
Twenty, twenty two is going to be nuts and twenty,
twenty four even more if Republicans succeed
in twenty twenty two either in the House Senate or
at the state level. So there is a lot to be afraid
of. And whatever you think about Max Boot on this,
I don't think he's being too alarmist. I think
he's exactly right. Let me know your thoughts. You
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. Follow me
there. And we'll be right back. The David Pakman
Show is made possible primarily by people who sign
up for memberships at Join Pakman Dotcom, if you
miss the Monday Memorial Day membership discount
Fearnot, you can take advantage of it through
the end of the week. The coupon code is Memorial
21. It'll work to discount any
membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.